[موسيقى]
مساء الخير سؤال بسيط لماذا تتسابق كثير
من دول العالم هذه الايام للانضمام لمنظمه
وهل منظمه بريكس نواه لتشكيل نظام عالمي
جديد بقياده الصين على انقاذ الامبراطوريه
الامريكيه قبل محاوله الاجابه على
السؤالين دول من المهمه ان نطرح سؤالا
ثالثا ابسط كثيرا ما هي اساسا
اقتصادي تشكل في عام 2009 وبدا به اربع
دول فقط الاربع دول دي هي الصين والهند
وروسيا والبرازيل ثم انضمت اليهم جنوب
افريقيا في العام التالي وما ثالث وما زال
هذا التكتل اقتصر على الدول الخمسه
الاعضاء المؤسسين
اسم بريكس جاي من الحروف الاولى لاسماء
الدول الخمسه باللغه الانجليزيه
ولذلك كان اسم التكتل في عام 2009 منظمه
البريك ثم اضيف اليها الاسم ثم اضيف اليها
الاسم اللي هو الحرف الاول من ثوره افريكا
في عام 2010 واصبحت تكتل اسمه بريكس ايه
اهداف هذه المنظمه نقدر نفهم اهداف
المنظمه بوضوح لما نركز على تاريخ التاسيس
عام 2009 عام 2009 ده كان العام التالي
لاندلاع الازمه الماليه العالميه في 2008
الازمه التي خلقتها الولايات المتحده ولكن
غرق العالم كله فيها عام 2009 دعى الرئيس
الروسي وقتها دي متر منفرس ثلاث دول اخرى
هي الصين والهند والبرازيل الى همم روسيا
لاول قمه
اللي هي كانت نواه مؤسسه او منظمه البريكس
قبل ان تنضم اليهم جنوب افريقيا في العام
التالي وكان هدف المؤتمر او الاجتماع ان
تناقش دول ناميه تضررت من سياسات الولايات
المتحده كيف يمكن ان تخرج من هذه الازمه
لكن في البيان الرئيس دي متر زاريف اللي
هو الرئيس الروسي وقتها قال ان احنا
اجتمعنا وناقشنا سبل الخروج من الازمه
الماليه العالميه ولكن توافقنا على ان
يكون تعاوننا اكبر مش بس ازاي نخرج من
الازمه ولكن كيف يمكن ان نخلق نظاما
عالميا جديدا اكثر عدله وضع تحت اكثر عددا
كثير عده خطوط نظام عالميا جديده اكثر
عدلا اذا المنظمه من البدايه هي صرخ
الاحتكاك يا صرخه احباط من النظام العالمي
الذي تقوده الو المتحده
وفشلها في قياده هذا النظام بشكل يراعي
مصالح كل الاطراف الاخرى
ظلت المنظمه مغلقه على نفسها حتى عام 2017
في عام 2017 اقترحت الصين ان يكون هناك ما
يسمى ببركس بلس يعني الاعضاء الخمس ثم
اضافه اعضاء جدد ولكن بشكل غير رسمي يعني
يتم دعوه دول اخرى كمراقبين كشركاء حوار
يعني الدول الاخرى سوف تحضر مؤتمرات قمه
بريكس لا تتمتع صحيح بعضويه كامله ولكنها
سوف تشارك مع دول البريكس تحاول ان تعظم
تعاونها مع هذه الدول
في يونيو الماضي 2022
اعلن الرئيس الروسي انه الدول الخمسه
توافقت على ان تفتح باب العضويه لاعضاء
الجدد والرئيس الروسي والرئيس الصيني قال
مرغب في تسريع فتح باب العضويه وضم عدد من
الاعضاء الجدد
مين الاعضاء الجدد اللي قبضه اهتمامهم
بمنظمه بريكس بمجرد ما فتحت المنظمه
ابوابها خمس دول ابدت اهتمامها بشكل كبير
في نفس الشهر اللي هو يونيو 2022 الشهر
الذي اعلن فيه رئيس الصين عن فتح باب
العضويه تقدم الدوله
الارجنتين وايران وبدا الثلاث دول اخرى في
التفاوض مع المنظمه للانضمام اليها رسميا
الدول الثلاثه
تركيه ومصر والسعوديه يبقى احنا امام خمس
دول بتسعى الان
للانضمام العضويه بريكس ايران الارجنتين
تركيا مصر السعوديه لكن في عدد كبير من
الدول هم على رادار منظمه بروكسي يعني
المنظمه والتكتل يسعى لضمها دول زي مين زي
اندونيسيا زي نيجيريا زي تايلاند زي دوله
الامارات وفي الاكثر بتتطلع للانضمام
وعبرت عن ذلك رسميه مثل الجزائر على سبيل
المثال اللي اعلن رئيسها مؤخرا انه راغب
في الانضمام الى المنظمه
المنظمه مش بتتطلع لضم اي دوله هي بتتطلع
لدول بتعتبرها نوت كونتريس دول العقد دول
المحوريه يعني دول بتتمتع بموقع استراتيجي
دول بتتمتع باصوات كبيره دول بتتمتع به
تنشل احتمال الازدهار الاقتصادي اذا ما
توافرت لها عوامل متعدده منها دعم دول
بريكس لها
نعود الى السؤال مره اخرى لماذا تتسابق
كثير من دول العالم الان للانضمام لمنظمه
بريكس اول سبب طبعا سبب اجراء احنا لسه
قايلين وان المنظمه ما كانتش فاتحه
ابوابها لكنها فتحت ابوابها مؤخرا فقط في
هدوء الماضي لكن يظل السؤال قائما لماذا
فتحت بريكس ابوابها الان ولماذا تسابق عدد
من دول العالم للدخول الى هذا الباب
الاجابه باختصار هو اجواء التوتر
والاستقطاب التي يشهدها العالم بعد انطلاع
الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه ومع تصاعد
التوتر بين الغرب والشرق ممثلا في الصين
وفي روسيا طبعا
اجواء الاستقطاب اللي بيعيشها العالم الان
في 2022 بتشبه الى حد كبير اجواء الحرب
البارده التي شهدها العالم من نهايه الحرب
العالميه الثانيه وحتى سقوط الاتحاد
السوفيتي في نهايه عام 1991
كان في اجواء الحرب البارده معسكرين
اساسيين معسكر بقياده الاتحاد السوفيتي
اللي هو المعسكر الشرقي ومعسكر اخر غرب
بقياده الولايات المتحده وفي اجواء الحرب
البارده والاستقطاب كل معسكر فيهم كان
بيسعى لضم اكبر عدد ممكن من الحلفاء نحن
عدنا الى هذه المرحله مره اخرى ونعيش
اجواء حرب بارده بين معسكر بتقوده الصين
ومعسكر بتقوده الولايات المتحده ومره اخرى
بيسعى كل معسكر لضم اكبر عدد ممكن من
الحلفاء ولذلك ليس غريبا انه منظمه بريكس
باعضائها الخمسه بقياده الصين وروسيا
ويعني
الدول الثلاثه الاخرى تسعى لضم الدول
تعتقد انها تمثل اضافه مثل الدول التي
التي اشارته اليها
وبالتالي الدول همم المنظمه حريصه على ضم
هذه الدول لما تمثله من اضافه كبيره
والدول اللي عاوز تنضم للبريكس تعتقد ان
الانضمام الى البريكس سوف يعزز قوتها
الاقتصاديه والسياسيه بشكل كبير كل دوله
عندها سوء وعندها موارد الاسواق تحتاج الى
موارد والموارد تحتاج الى اسواق يعني مثلا
اذا اخذنا مثال ايران عندها موارد على
راسها البترول والغاز البترول والغاز ده
كبير جدا بحيث انه يفيض على الاحتياج
المحلي وبالتالي بيبحث عن اسواق والدول دي
بترحب به
البترول والغاز الايراني بعيدا عن الحظر
والعقومات الغربيه
وايران على سبيل المثال دوله فيها سوق
السوق يحتاج الى موارد اخرى خلاف البترول
والغاز والاسواق او الدول الاخرى اللي
موجوده في بريكس مستعده ان تعطي ايران ما
يمنعه الغرب عنها ده على سبيل المثاله
وبالتالي كل بلد يحتاج ما لدى الطرف الاخر
وبالتالي يبقى في عمليه تكامل والجميع
يستفيد في سبب ثاني بالنسبه للدول الحريصه
جدا على الانضمام وهي انه همم البريكس
بيمثل فرصه فريده سواء للدول لنعيم من
الدول الدول المعادله للولايات المتحده
والدول اللي هي غير معاديه او صديقه
للولايات المتحده الى هما يجدوا البريكس
جذابا جدا وتقدر تقسم كل الدول المنضمه او
التي ترغب في الانضمام الى البكس الى فين
دول معاداه لامريكا والدول تعتبرها صديقه
لامريكا الدول المعاديه واضحه جدا طبعا
ابرز مثال هو ايران ايران بواقعه تحت
العقوبات الغربيه منذ عام 1979 وكل يوم
الضغوط بتتزايد عليها من المعسكر الغربي
من الدول الاعضاء بالفعل طبعا الصين هي
تدرك تماما ان الولايات المتحده بتستهدف
اضعافها وبتستهدف وقف نموها الاقتصادي
وصعودها كقوه كبيره
روسيا في نفس هذا المعسكر الدول اللي هي
معادله للولايات المتحده ببساطه لانها
مشتبكه الان منذ فبراير الماضي في حرب مع
الولايات المتحده وحلفائها حرب بالوكاله
على اراضي اوكرانيا هذه نموذج للدول التي
هي موجوده في بريكس او التاسعه للانضمام
الى بريكس وهي معادله للولايات المتحده
هذا هو الدافع الاساسي لوجودها في بريكس
لكن في دول اخرى هي تعتبر صديقه للولايات
المتحده اما انها على علاقه طيبه مثل
الجزائر مثل مصر او انها على علاقه خاصه
جدا مثل الامارات والسعوديه السعوديه
والامارات بتربيتهم به الولايات المتحده
ليس مجرد صداقه ولكن علاقه خاصه ترابط
كبير جدا ودول اخرى علاقتها بالولايات
المتحده بتتجاوز الصداقه او العلاقه
الطيبه وتتجاوز العلاقه الخاصه الى مرحله
التحالف سيئه تركيا لان تركيا مرتبطه مع
الولايات المتحده بتحالف من خلال حلف شمال
الاطلسي الدول الثلاثه ديت او او الانواع
الثلاثه دول من الدول حريصه ان تتواجد فيه
بريكس
اما لانها حريصه ان تضع يد يعني قدم لها
اوساقا لها في اكثر من معسكر علشان تعزز
من قوتها على الساحه الدوليه في اجواء
الاستقطاب في دول بتحب ان هي لا تقف في
معسكر واحد ولكن ان تعدد المعسكرات التي
تنتمي اليها حتى تحافظ على قدرتها وعلى
استقلالها الوطني بالمناسبه اوضح مثلا ما
ذكرتوش اللي هو الهند الهند موجوده في
بريكس وموجوده في نفس الوقت في اكثر من
منظمه بتقودها الى الولايات المتحده
وعندها تاريخ طويل في قياده حركه عدم
الانحياز ان هي تحافظ على علاقات طيبه بكل
المعسكرات
في سبب اضافي ان بعض اصدقاء امريكا فقدوا
الثقه فيها وابرز مثال واقرب مثال الى
اذهاننا هي الدول الخليج دول الصديقه
للوايات المتحده ولكنها ملت من ضغوط
امريكا وتناقضاتها وعدم موثوقيتها
ويعني وبتكلمني عن القصه دي كثيرا دول
الخليج ودول عربيه كثيرا بتنظر الى امريكا
على انها تاجر يتمتع بوضع احتكاري في سوق
ماء التاجر لما يكون بيتمتع بوضع احتكاري
بيقول لزبائنه عاجبك عاجبك مش عاجبك لن
تجد غيري هكذا كانت تتعامل الولايات
المتحده مع كثير من اصدقائها ما انه جد
هؤلاء الاصدقاء بديلا يتشكل ممثلا في
بريكس
هرعوا اليه على امل انه يكون في بديل اخر
عن هيمنه وسيطرت الولايات المتحده
السؤال
هل يمثل البريكس نواه لتشكيل
نظام عالمي جديد بتقوده الصين الاجابه
قولا واحدا
الاجابه نعم قولا واحدا هذا التصور تشكيل
نظام جديد موجود في ادهان الدول التي شكلت
هذا التحالف والدول التي تسعى للانضمام
اليه
لماذا سبب الاولاني احنا قلناه في اول
الحلقه التشكل هذا التحالف قام في الاساس
في 2009
كاحتجاج على قياده الولايات المتحده
الفاشله من وجهه نظرهم في قياده العالم
والكلام اللي قاله مدفيد الناس عالي تشكيل
نظام عالمي اكثر عدلا الكلام ده قاله في
2009 سفير الارجنتين لما
اجرح حوارا مع مجله او جريده جلوبال تايمز
الصينيه في يوليو 2022 قال لك لبن مشابها
بيقول احنا ليه حريصين على الانضمام الى
المنظمه اول سبب قاله القناعاتنا ان وجود
منظمه البريكس واليتها هي اضافه مهمه جدا
لخلق عالم جديد يعني نظام عالمي جديد اكثر
تعدديه واكثر توازنا في مراعاه مصالح
الدول الاخرى ده رقم واحد يعني علنا وهمم
يعني كلام مواربه فيه ثم اضاف انه احنا
حريصين على الانضمام كارجنتين الى منظمه
بركس لانه لا توجد مشروطيات يعني لما
بنجيء نتعاون معاهم ما بيحطوا لناش عده
شروط كما تفعل الولايات المتحده على كل
عقد او على كل صفقه او على كل همم يعني
تعامل مع امريكا وحلفائها
والتعاون مع منظمه بريكس يصب في مصلحه
الجميع وليس في مصلحه دوله واحده في اشاره
الى الولايات المتحده واضاف شيء مهم جدا
ثم انه نفوذ البريكس يتزايد يوما بعد يوما
وهناك خبراء يعتقدون ان اقتصاد اقتصادات
مجموعه بريكس سوف تتفوق على اجمالي
اقتصادات دول السبع الكبرى اللي هي
بتقودها الولايات المتحده
هذا اولا الامر الثاني انه التكتل ده
بوضعه الحالي قبل اضافه اعداء جوده قبل
اضافه اعضاء جدد وتكتر قوي جدا
التكتل القوي ده يعني ممكن اديكم عده
ارقام على ماذا قوته بوضع الحالي هو بيضم
اكثر من ثلاثه مليار مثلا ثلاثه مليار
و200 او 300 مليون نسمه
دول بيمثلوا اكثر من 40% من سكان الارض
اللي هم بيقتربوا من الثمانيه مليار
بيمثلوا من مساحه الكره الارضيه حوالي 30%
بيمثلوا 25% او اكتر شويه من اجمال الناتج
المحلي للعالم كله بيمثلوا حوالي 18 او
20% من التجاره
العالميه وبالتالي هو تكتل ضخم جدا
وبيسيطر على موارد بالغه الاهميه لكل
العالم يعني روسيا هي اكبر مصدر للقمح
البرازيل هي اكبر مصدر لفول الصويا همم
الهندي اكبر مصدر للارز روسيا قوه عظمى في
البترول والغاز اذا انضم الى هذا التكتل
ايران والسعوديه والامارات هيصبح قوه عظمى
في مجال الطاقه التقليديه انا باتكلم على
بريكس ثم ان الهند والصين
يعني قوه كبيره في مجال الطاقه المتجدده
والنظيفه والصين على وجه التحديد سبقت
الدول الغربيه في تطوير تكنولوجيا توليد
الطاقه المتجدده الى درجه ان الولايات
المتحده بتعتقد ان اللحظه التي سوف ينتقل
فيها العالم من الوقود الاحفوري الى
الطاقه المتجدده سوف يكون عصر الصين لا
عصر الولايات المتحده لان الصين سبقت
الغرب كثيرا في هذا المجال الخلاصه ان
احنا بنتكلم على تكتل بوضعه الحالي تكتل
كبير وقويرا فماذا لو اضيفت اليه كل هذه
الدول القويه الواعده همم سوف يصبح تكتلا
اقوى واكثر والتكتل ده مش قوي فقط ده قوي
وطموح وكثير من اعضائه مضار من الولايات
المتحده ونظامها رابعا النظام العالمي
اللي بتقوده الولايات المتحده الان والذي
تاسس من خلال اتفاقيه وانت عام 1944 قام
على اليات محدده اهمها صندوق النقد الدولي
والبنك الدوري البنك الدولي كانت وما زالت
وظيفته تمويل التنميه في الدول الصديقه
والحليفه والصندوق صندوق النقد هدفه
الاساسي ضبط النظام النقدي اي اسعار الصرف
واسعار العملات المختلفه امام الدولار وفي
هذا النظام بيلعب الدولار المركزي
والمحوري
سنه 2014 قامت بريكس بتاسيس البنك الجديد
لبريكس وهذا البنك الجديد راس ماله يعادل
100 مليار دولار وضع تحته كلمه شعاد العده
خطوط لانه الاموال اللي موجوده فيه تعادل
المئه مليار دولار من عملات المحليه لهذه
الدول وظيفه هذا البنك ان يمول التنميه في
الدول الخمس الاعضاء البريكس ولكن
باستخدام العملات المحليه لهذه الدول وليس
باستخدام الدولار ما يعني انه خطوه لتهنيش
الدولار وضربه
الدولار
الامريكيه في مقتل وبالتالي ما فيش ما
يدعو للدهشه ابدا ان الولايات المتحده
تنظر الى هذا التحالف بكثير من الخوف
والترقب والقلق
اجابه السؤال هل هذا يمثل نوال لتشكيل
تحالف
يقوم على انقاذ الامبراطوريه الامريكيه
نعم هذا موجود كهدف غير معلن بشكل رسمي ما
فيش اعضاء يعني الرؤساء او المسؤولين
الرسميين لا يتحدثون عن ذلك وما بيتحدثوا
عن تعاون اقتصادي يعني لصالحهم ولصالح
الجميع وبيقولوا ده مش تحالف مغلق اهلا
وسهلا اي حد ممكن ينضم اليه لكن من الواضح
جدا ان توجههم هو سلولي باتشولي او يعني
رويدا رويدا يكونوا نواه لنظام عالميا
جديد على انقاذ النظام الذي تقوده
الولايات المتحده لكن يتبقى ان نقول ان
يكون عندك الطموح ان تبني نظام العالميه
الجديده شيء وان تنجح فيه بنائه شيئا اخر
لانه هناك تحديات كبيره جدا امام الدول
البريكس وامام جهود بعض اعضائه لتشكيل
نظام عالمي جديد ولكن هذه قصه اخرى في
اشاره سريعه ما زلت هناك تناقضات كثيره
بين الدول اعضاء بريكس واهدافهم يعني
اهداف الصين وروسيا ليست هي اهداف الهند
مثلا التي تضع قدمها في مع البريكس وتضع
قدمها مع المعسكر الغربي ولديها تناقضات
مع امريكا ولكن ايضا لديها تناقضات
وخلافات مع الصين وخلافات حدوديه اهداف
النصر والدول الخليج تختلف عن اهداف مثلا
ايران وبالتالي هناك تناقضات الامر الثاني
انه الولايات المتحده وهي القوه العظمى
حتى الان تشعر بالقلق الشديد والدول
الكبرى تكون اكثر خطرا واكثر عدوانا حين
تشعر ان هيمنتها باتت مهدده وبالتالي لن
تقف الولايات المتحده
وحلفائها مكتوب في الايدي وهم يرون
البريكس نفود البريكس يتصاعده يوما بعد
يوم ماذا يمكن ان يحدث ماذا يمكن ان يفعل
البريكس ماذا يمكن ان تفعل الولايات
المتحده هذه قصه اخرى نراقبها ان شاء الله
باهتمام ويكون لنا معها حلقه اخرى باذن
الله اشكركم والى اللقاء